que nosotros mismos extendimos
y de la que ahora parece que no podemos reconocer ni deshacernos.
PV: No estamos allí todavía.
Hoy, estamos aquí para elevar nuestros estándares de alfabetización racial,
para redefinir lo que significa ser racialmente alfabetizado.
WG: Queremos que en todas partes de EE. UU.
nuestras generaciones más jóvenes y las futuras crezcan equipadas
con las herramientas para comprender, navegar y mejorar
un mundo estructurado por división racial.
Queremos que todos imaginemos la comunidad como un lugar
en que no solo nos sentimos orgullosos de nuestros orígenes,
sino también invierte en las experiencias de los demás como si fueran nuestras.
PV: Acabamos de graduarnos de secundaria el pasado mes de junio.
WG: Y pensarán...
(Aplausos)
Y pensarán después de 12 años
alguien dentro o fuera del aula nos ayudará a entender...
PV: En un nivel básico al menos...
WG: La sociedad en la que vivimos.
PV: La verdad para casi todos nuestros compañeros de clase es que no lo hacen.
WG: En las comunidades de nuestro país, muchas de ellas divididas por raza,
PV: si no buscas educación sobre raza,
para alfabetización racial...
WG: No lo conseguirás.
No vendrá sin más a ti.
PV: Incluso cuando tuvimos conversaciones sobre raza,
nuestra comprensión fue siempre superficial.
Nos dimos cuenta de que hay dos grandes brechas
en nuestra alfabetización racial.
WG: Primero, la brecha del corazón:
una incapacidad para entender cada una de nuestras experiencias,
para intensamente y sin disculpas ser compasivos más allá de los labios.
PV: Y segundo, la brecha mental: una incapacidad para comprender
las formas más amplias y sistemáticas en que opera el racismo.
WG: Primero, la brecha del corazón.
Para ser justos, la raza apareció algunas veces en la escuela.
Todos defendemos nuestra educación sobre justicia social
porque aprendimos sobre Martin Luther King Jr.
y Harriet Tubman y Rosa Parks.
Pero incluso en todas esas conversaciones,
la raza siempre se sintió pasada de moda, como,
"Sí, la esclavitud, sucedió una vez,
pero ¿por qué realmente importa ahora?".
Como resultado, realmente no nos importó.
Pero ¿qué pasa si nuestro maestro presenta una historia desde el presente,
por ejemplo, cómo Treniya nos dijo en Pittsburgh que...
PV: "Mi hermana estaba revisando Facebook y tecleó nuestro apellido.
Este tipo blanco apareció,
y descubrimos que su tatara-tatara-abuelo poseía esclavos
y mi tatara-tatara-tatara-tatarabuela fue uno de ellos.
Mi apellido... no es quien soy.
Hemos vivido bajo el nombre de un hombre blanco.
Si la esclavitud no hubiera sucedido, ¿quién sería yo?".
WG: Ahora se siente relevante, inmediato, porque la conexión
con el legado perdurable de la esclavitud hoy está clara, ¿verdad?
O lo que sucedería es que nuestro maestro arrojaría estadísticas frías.
Probablemente ya han visto esto en los titulares de las noticias.
PV: Los afroamericanos son encarcelados
más de cinco veces la tasa de personas blancas.
WG: Ahora consideren a Ronnie, en Seattle.
PV: "Mi padre significa todo para mí.
Él es todo lo que tengo, no conozco a mi madre.
Mi padre fue encarcelado erróneamente por 12 años.
Tengo una hija e intento ser la misma figura paternal para ella:
siempre involucrado en todo lo que hace, incluso hasta molesto en algunos puntos.
Pero me temo que me perderé en su vida
al igual que mi padre lo hizo en la mía".
WG: Lanzar solo la estadística, únicamente los hechos solos,
desconectados de los humanos reales,
puede llevar a una comprensión peligrosamente incompleta de esos hechos.
No reconoce que para muchas personas que no entienden el racismo
el problema no es la falta de conocimiento
para hablar sobre el dolor de la supremacía blanca y la opresión,
es que no reconocen que ese dolor existe en absoluto.
No reconocen a los seres humanos que están siendo afectados,
y no sienten lo suficiente como para preocuparse.
PV: Segundo, la brecha mental.
No podemos ignorar las estadísticas, tampoco.
No podemos entender realmente la situación de Ronnie
sin entender que cosas como leyes injustas y vigilancia policial sesgada,
racismo sistemático,
ha producido las tasas de encarcelamiento desproporcionadas en el tiempo.
O como en Honolulu,
la gran población carcelaria de hawaianos nativos como Kimmy
está muy influenciada por la larga historia de la isla
de colonización estadounidense,
es un impacto que pasa de generación en generación hasta nuestros días.
Para nosotros, a veces hablamos
sobre las experiencias personales únicas de las personas en el aula.
Cosas como, cómo Justin nos dijo una vez...
WG: "He estado trabajando en reclamar psicológicamente mi lugar en esta ciudad.
Porque para mí, mi Chicago no es la bonita arquitectura del centro,
no es el North Side.
Mi Chicago es la línea naranja, la línea rosa, la clase trabajadora de inmigrantes
yendo en el tren".
PV: Y si bien podríamos haber reconocido su experiencia personal,
no habríamos hablado acerca de cómo la línea roja
y la segregación legalizada de nuestro pasado
creó los barrios racialmente divididos en los que vivimos hoy.
No habríamos entendido completamente
cómo el racismo está incrustado en el marco de todo lo que nos rodea,
porque nos mantendríamos concentrados en las experiencias aisladas de las personas.
Otro ejemplo, Sandra en DC una vez nos dijo:
WG: "Cuando estoy con mi familia coreana, sé cómo moverme con ellos.
Sé qué hacer para que sientan que me importan.
Y hacer y compartir comida
es una de las formas más fundamentales de mostrar amor.
Con mi compañero que no es coreano, sin embargo,
hemos tenido que lidiar con el hecho
de que estoy muy centrada en la comida y él simplemente no.
Una vez dijo que no quería que lo esperara
para hacer comida para mí,
y me enojé mucho".
PV: Eso podría parecer una reacción extraña,
pero solo si no reconocemos que es emblemático de algo más grande,
algo más profundo.
Trauma intrageneracional.
Como en la familia de Sandra, el hambre y la pobreza generalizadas
existieron tan recientemente como la generación de los padres de Sandra
y por tanto, tiene un impacto en Sandra hoy.
Ella experimenta a alguien diciendo:
WG: "No quiero alimentarte".
PV: Como...
WG: "No quiero abrazarte".
PV: Y sin ella y su pareja teniendo esa comprensión matizada
de su reacción y el contexto histórico detrás de ella,
podría conducir fácilmente a una pelea innecesaria.
Es por eso que es tan importante que actuemos de forma proactiva
(Ambos hablando): Cocrear...
PV: Una cultura estadounidense compartida
que identifica y abarca los diferentes valores y normas
dentro de nuestras diversas comunidades.
WG: Para ser alfabetizado racialmente
PV: Para entender quiénes somos para que podamos sanarnos juntos...
WG: no podemos descuidar el corazón
PV: ni la mente.
Así, con nuestros cientos de historias,
decidimos publicar un libro de texto de alfabetización racial
para cerrar esa brecha entre nuestros corazones y mentes.
WG: Nuestro último libro, "The Classroom Index"
comparte historias profundamente personales.
PV: Y combina esas historias personales
con la brillante investigación de estadísticos y académicos.
WG: Cada día, aún estamos impresionadas por las experiencias de las personas,
por la complejidad de nuestra realidad racial colectiva.
PV: Y hoy, les preguntamos
WG: ¿Están alfabetizados racialmente?
¿Ya lo lograron?
PV: ¿Realmente entienden a las personas que los rodean,
sus historias, historias como estas?
No es solo saber que Louise de Seattle
sobrevivió a los campos de internamiento japones estadounidenses.
Es saber que, mientras tanto,
su esposo era uno de los aproximadamente 33 000 japoneses americanos
que pelearon por nuestro país durante la guerra,
un país que simultáneamente estaba internando a sus familias.
La mayoría de nosotros hoy olvidamos la valentía resistencia e historia
de esos japoneses estadounidenses en campos y en servicio,
Se han convertido solo en víctimas.
PV: No es solo saber que los matrimonios interraciales
como Shermaine y Paul en DC existen,
es reconocer que nuestra sociedad ha sido programada para que fallen.
Que en su primera cita alguien gritó:
"¿Por qué estás con esa puta negra?".
Eso de acuerdo con un estudio de Columbia sobre relaciones cisgénero
el negro a menudo se equipara con la masculinidad
y asiático con feminidad, lo que lleva a más hombres
a no valorar a las mujeres negras y fetichizar a las mujeres asiáticas.
Entre los matrimonios blanco y negro en el año 2000,
el 73 % tenía un marido negro y una esposa blanca.
Paul y Shermaine desafían esa estadística.
Negro es hermoso,
pero se necesita mucho para creerlo, una vez que la sociedad diga lo contrario.
WG: No es solo saber que los blancos como Lisa en Chicago
tienen el privilegio blanco,
que se refleja conscientemente en el término blancura y su historia,
sabiendo que la blancura no se puede equiparar con EE. UU.
Es saber que Lisa no puede olvidar la historia de su propia familia
de la opresión judía.
Que ella no puede olvidar cómo, al crecer,
fue llamada una judía sucia con cuernos y colas.
Pero Lisa sabe que puede pasar como blanca
se beneficia de enormes privilegios sistémicos e interpersonales,
y entonces pasa todos los días
lidiando con formas en que puede aprovechar ese privilegio blanco
para la justicia social.
Por ejemplo, iniciar conversaciones con otras personas de privilegio sobre raza.
O cambiando el poder de su clase a sus estudiantes
aprendiendo a escuchar sus experiencias de racismo y pobreza.
PV: No es solo saber que los idiomas nativos están muriendo.
Es apreciar la fluidez en el lenguaje Cherokee,
que realmente solo hablan menos de 12 000 personas hoy,
es un acto de supervivencia, de preservación de la cultura y la historia.
Es saber cómo el lenguaje Cherokee sin género
permitió la aceptación de Ahyoka como mujer trans
en Tahlequah, Oklahoma.
Su abuela le dijo firmemente un dicho en Cherokee,
"Yo no digo quién eres,
tú dices quién eres.
Y eso es lo que eres".
WG: Estas son solo partes de algunas historias.
Hay aproximadamente 323 millones de personas en EE. UU.
PV: Y 7,4 miles de millones de personas en el planeta.
WG: Así que tenemos mucho que escuchar.
PV: Y mucho que aprender.
WG: Tenemos que subir el listón.
PV: Elevar nuestros estándares de alfabetización racial.
Porque sin invertir en una educación que valora...
WG: ambas historias... PV: y estadísticas...
WG: la gente... PV: y los números...
WG: lo interpersonal... PV: y lo sistémico...
WG: Siempre habrá una pieza faltante.
PV: Hoy, muy pocos de nosotros nos entendemos.
WG: No sabemos cómo comunicarnos,
PV: Vivan juntos... WG: Ámense unos a otros.
Necesitamos trabajar juntos para crear una nueva comunidad nacional.
PV: Una nueva cultura compartida de sufrimiento mutuo y celebración.
WG: Necesitamos comenzar a aprender en nuestras propias comunidades locales,
cerrar las brechas entre nuestros propios corazones y mentes
llegar a ser racialmente letrados.
PV: Una vez que todos lo hagamos, estaremos mucho más cerca
a vivir en espacios y sistemas que luchan y se preocupan por igual para todos.
WG: Entonces, ninguno de nosotros podrá permanecer distante.
PV: No podríamos... perdón mamá y papá, la universidad puede esperar.
WG: Estamos en un año sabático,
viajando a los 50 estados, coleccionando historias para nuestro próximo libro.
PV: Y aún nos quedan 23 estados para entrevistar.
(Ambas) Vamos a trabajar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)